could you share maybe could you provide
give us an insight into your a language
learning method that you developed in
the course of in the course of 20 years
starting from 15 well it's it's a we
don't have much time to talk about it
because you know it would take a long
time anyway
but I would say to make a long story
short right I would say that what I do
is you know languages are like sisters
so when you have one system which is
your own native tongue and then you have
the other system the target language
you have to understand how to figure out
how the other the other system works and
so what I did is I use a bi-directional
translation technique meaning that I use
my own native tongue as a crutch as a
help to figure out how the other
language works and by translating things
back and forth meaning from say let's
suppose that I'm learning German so I
take for example I translate from German
into Italian and by translating it to my
own native tongue I make sure that I
understand everything because you cannot
translate something if you don't
understand it so this is the analytical
part so to say and then I translate it
back into German in order to figure out
how the language works by doing so you
know if you translate from from your
target language into your own native
tongue it's not that complicated but
when it comes to translating it back a
few days later you will figure out that
first it's much more difficult and then
you actually help to figure out you know
the nuts and bolts of the language and
figure out how different languages
conveyed the same message and by doing
that I just form a like what I call a
language core meaning that I don't I do
learn words obviously because words are
important for if you want to speak
fluently but the first and foremost I
learned how to assemble the pieces
together like the Lego
you know I learn how to to form
sentences
you don't need according to the
statistics actually the amount of words
that we use in daily conversation is
it's just a tiny part of the overall
amount of words that exist in a language
so what I do is first I make sure that I
am able to put things together and then
obviously I add quantity to quality so
at the big
it's quality work I work on the language
according to by and through this
technique and anything I expanded